[Music]
on this tuesday night a potential
seismic shift in abortion law in the u.s
the leaked supreme court draft ruling
and the reaction that our deepest fears
are coming true unborn are human and
we've been killing them in mass plus the
potential ripple effects in canada
relief after being rescued from a
besieged steel plant
you can't imagine how scary it is and in
chernia of ukraine one man who keeps
reliving the war decision ontario when
that province heads to the polls
and a hockey legend laid to rest when
guillermo walked into a room jaws
dropped the amazing power and influence
of gila fleur on and off the ice
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
for decades the law about abortion in
the united states has been settled it is
legal well now there are signs of a
seismic shift coming a draft ruling by
the u.s supreme court leaked to the
media reveals the top court could be
poised to overturn a landmark 1973
ruling called roe versus wade which
guarantees the right to abortion across
the nation the leaked document labeled
first draft appears to reflect the
majority opinion of the court justice
samuel alito states roe was egregiously
wrong from the start its reasoning was
exceptionally weak and the decision has
had damaging consequences
that a supreme court ruling was leaked
is itself unprecedented the court today
called it a betrayal of the confidences
of the court and this draft written in
february could still change but those
who have long feared a conservative
majority on the court intends to make a
fundamental shift in law are shaken to
their core
concerns be a great deal
that we're going to after 50 years
decide a woman does not have a right to
choose within the limits of the supreme
court decision but even more
equally as profound is the rationale
used the draft opinion if it holds would
allow states to declare abortion illegal
and many states already have laws ready
to go there is concern too about what
message this sends to other countries
including canada we'll get to that in a
moment but we begin with jackson prosco
in washington
neither side in the abortion debate saw
this coming at least not like this a
leaked draft decision suggesting the
supreme court is about to overturn
abortion rights in america it's good
news for for um for the pro-life
movement something that we've been
fighting for for almost 50 years to try
to overturn roe if they're willing to
undo 50 years of a precedent
safe abortion access for all of us
across this country what else are they
willing to do the draft argues the right
to abortion is not deeply rooted in
american history or traditions it says
abortion rights should be decided by
politicians not the courts the ruling is
not yet final but could be by summer if
roe is ultimately overturned more than
half the states are considered certain
or likely to ban abortion entirely
13 states already have so-called trigger
bans on the books that take effect
automatically the moment roe is
overturned
many of those states make no exception
for cases of rape or incest
legally what we're talking about is a
movement that's willing to go so far in
state legislatures
as to criminally charge people with
murder
in cases of miscarriage and stillbirth
stunning as it is progressives say the
fight is not just about abortion the
conservative majority court could simply
find reason to overturn other rights
like same-sex marriage or access to
contraceptives it basically says
all the decisions related to your
private life
who you marry
whether or not you decide to conceive a
child or not whether or not you can have
an abortion yet reversing roe is at odds
with the views of most americans polls
show a majority oppose overturning it
and most approve of at least some
abortion rights the blame for this
decision
falls squarely on senate republicans who
spent years pushing extremist judges
democrats are now pushing legislation to
guarantee abortion rights in law they
may have the support of at least some
republicans who seemed surprised that
conservative justices they nominated to
the court would support such drastic
changes to american life if it goes in
the direction that this leaked copy has
has indicated
i will just tell you that it it
it
it rocks my confidence in in the court
right now
jackson there are some people including
republican senators who believe recent
supreme court nominees lied to the
public about their views on reproductive
rights during their confirmation
hearings which took place under oath
so what happens with that what happens
next
well donna it all depends on what the
final ruling looks like later on this
summer but as you heard some republicans
are signaling they may in fact vote in
favor of federal legislation to support
abortion rights not clear they would
have the votes with democrats to get
that pass though we should point out
that republicans themselves largely seem
uncertain with what to do with all of
this they're not touting this as some
big victory right now instead they would
rather make the message about the leak
from the supreme court itself
all right jackson in washington thanks
other countries are watching closely
what's happening in the u.s here in
canada abortion is legal and it's a
publicly funded medical procedure though
access does vary depending on where you
live those who believe in a woman's
right to choose are on high alert
fearing rights could be eroded here too
heather urix west reports
autumn reinhardt simpson has spent much
of her life helping people access
abortions first in her home country of
the united states and now from where she
lives in edmonton alberta here in
alberta we have three clinics but they
are focused in calgary and edmonton so
we still have a hard time getting people
in rural areas into the cities for their
appointments abortions are one of the
most common surgical procedures in
canada they are funded under provincial
health plans and legally available
across the country but often access is
not simple a lot of times i'm just kind
of driving around the province picking
people up or
things like that so that takes time that
takes gas that takes food that takes
child care you've just got all of these
logistics to think about that can
present really severe barriers
especially for indigenous people and
especially indigenous people living
outside of the city and if the procedure
becomes harder to access in the united
states it could compound matters in
canada in canada nowadays the vast
majority of abortions you know among
canadians happens in canada but very
rarely for late diagnoses of abnormal
pregnancies or a late diagnosis of
pregnancy in a socially complicated
situation
patients may have the option of
traveling to the united states while
national statistics are not available
more than 100 women in ontario have
traveled to the us for an abortion in
the last 10 years and as u.s state
abortion bans take effect advocates
expect to see more patients coming here
i think most of the traveling in the
united states will go towards the
nearest possible option so for some
people that will be canada
and so that will of course put pressure
on an already overburdened health system
here in our own country i suspect that
we'll see an increase in orders for
methopristone across the united states
that could translate to drug shortages
for the abortion pill in canada while
roe v wade passed in 1973
abortions didn't become widely and
legally accessible in canada until
1989.
thirty years later while that right
remains in place it's one canadian
advocates say should not be taken for
granted heather urex west global news
calgary
now to russia's war in ukraine the
largest city in western ukraine has been
hit by a series of airstrikes flames lit
up the night sky over levive after the
russian missile strikes the city's mayor
says three electrical substations were
among the damaged buildings and that
caused a power outage
and the russian assault on the steel
plant in mariopol which only led up
briefly to allow a few dozen civilians
to escape is still going on there is
some good news about those who got out
on sunday they finally arrived in the
ukrainian city of zapposia today
redmond shannon reports and a warning
some of the images in his story are
upsetting
the relief is palpable some show it with
smiles others with tears after a
grueling journey through back roads and
russian army checkpoints the azov style
evacuees arrive to safety the end of a
two-month nightmare beneath the
bombarded steelworks in mariupol
you can't imagine how scary it is when
you sit in the shelter in a wet and damp
basement which is bouncing shaking
every night we went to sleep and thought
about whether we would survive and wake
up
the united nations says 101 civilians
including 17 children made it out most
of them arriving in zapposia we would
have hoped that much more people would
be able to join the convoy
and to get out of hell some estimates
say around 200 civilians are still
inside the red cross says the renewed
bombardment of the plant since sunday
prevents any more evacuations extremely
concerned with the image we have seen
today we have seen that hostilities have
resumed brony technical
ukrainian forces claim those hostilities
now include tanks and ground troops and
that two civilian women were killed
overnight i have
one
message
for you today
ukraine will win
british prime minister boris johnson
gave a virtual address to ukraine's
parliament the first foreign leader to
do so since russia's invasion in
february you have proved them completely
wrong every one of those military
experts who said that ukraine would fall
johnson pledged another half billion
dollars in new military aid to ukraine
france's emanuel macron meanwhile spent
two hours on the phone with vladimir
putin demanding but not getting a
ceasefire agreement from the russian
leader redmond shannon double news
london
a plea for help coming up the aid of
flood-ravaged first nation is asking for
plus when people in canada's largest
province go to the polls
[Music]
for a total today of sixteen thousand
eight hundred and one and a twenty day
total of four hundred and seventy six
thousand nine hundred and eighty five
dollars congratulations
wow canadian matteo roach has done it
again that was her 20th win on jeopardy
and the 23 year old now has the fifth
longest winning run on the quiz show's
history she's got her sights set on the
next milestone the fourth longest
winning streak she needs 33 straight
wins to make it
ontario's premiere is hoping for another
win too ontario's 43rd general election
campaign is getting underway premier
doug ford met with the lieutenant
governor to formally dissolve the
province's legislature today the
election will happen on the 2nd of june
tonight eric sorenson looks at who is in
the running and the political dynamics
at play in canada's biggest province
over four years doug ford has dug
himself in and out of controversies from
covid restrictions to health care
funding to paving over green space yes
to putting shovels in the ground for new
highways but ontario has largely
survived the big issue the pandemic and
polls show the premier who steered the
province through it is now positioned to
win re-election folks june the second
will have a choice
and we're going to make sure this
province continues to prosper the
challenge for official opposition leader
andrea horvath is that her party the ndp
has only once formed government in
ontario job number one is to defeat doug
ford job number two for horvath is to
hold off stephen del duca who's trying
to revive the liberal party after its
massive defeat in 2018. people respond
favorably to our plan and to the dynamic
new candidates who are running with me
for del duca and horvath plan a is to
win plan b is to not finish third
obviously he'll want to become premier
but the real battle is is going to be
for second place who's going to form
official opposition premier ford has
ontario history on his side
in the last century conservatives have
won two-thirds of all ontario provincial
elections and every newly elected
conservative government has been
re-elected to a second term and there is
another distinctive voting pattern here
for the past 60 years the party in power
in ottawa has been like a trigger for
ontario to go the opposite way in 15 of
the last 16 provincial elections ontario
voters have picked a premier of a
different stripe from the sitting prime
minister with pierre trudeau came
conservative bill davis mulrooney saw
peterson and rey cretchen came and then
so did mike harris conservative stephen
harper spent a decade opposite liberal
premiers and only after justin trudeau
was elected did conservatives move back
into the ontario premier's office it's
an interesting thing that we do
as as canadians in a sense we don't want
to give too much power to one political
ideology or to one group of people and
as previous ontario premiers have
discovered smooth relations with the
other team in ottawa can be good
politics you know i don't know i just
put all these political stripes aside
we work so well together for ontarians
there's nothing contradictory going one
way federally and another provincially
and the current premier hopes that
history holds in 2022. eric sorenson
global news toronto
in manitoba the pegus first nation is
calling on the federal government to
deploy immediate military aid to help
the community deal with major spring
flooding the first nation 170 kilometers
north of winnipeg is one of eighteen
communities under a state of emergency
on monday more than one thousand people
who live there were ordered to leave
their homes the province says the fisher
river has now peaked but there's still a
risk of more ice jams that could back up
the water hundreds of homes are
surrounded and roads are completely
submerged chief glenn hudson says he's
never seen it this bad the water he says
is higher than the flood disaster in his
community in 2011.
the scars of cherniv ahead the trauma of
survivors in a war-torn ukrainian city
you're watching global national
[Music]
there's so much sadness and violence in
ukraine but occasional moments like this
too this is the first stance of a couple
who got married in the hospital 23 year
old oxana ballendina a nurse lost her
legs in a landmine explosion in march
she and her now husband were walking
home the newlyweds are now preparing to
go to germany so she can undergo
rehabilitation
all the lives lost and disrupted are
hard to take in one of the hardest hit
places in ukraine is the northern city
of cherniv amnesty international says an
airstrike in early march involved at
least eight unguided bombs that
indiscriminately hit civilians the city
played a key role in preventing russian
troops from advancing into the capital
kiev
russia has since retreated from the area
our europe bureau chief crystal
gemensing got a firsthand look at what
was left behind
some scars of war are obvious charred
buildings with gaping holes and
shattered glass
others are buried deep inside survivors
at the time of the explosion i was very
close to the place ighor markovic
recalls hearing the roar of an airplane
engine and seeing it fly low he didn't
need to explain what he saw next instead
he showed us his phone
and a video transporting us back two
months to march
[Music]
the chaos the sound of people screaming
the bodies on the ground the images are
hard to watch but ihor
lived it
see the line here at the place where we
are standing now
you can see the leg was blown off
amnesty international says up to eight
unguided bombs were dropped here killing
at least 47 people human rights watch
was unable to identify
any legitimate military targets in the
area and concluded the strike could
constitute a war crime
i don't see any logic in this war except
to destroy and kill people
[Music]
at saint catherine's cathedral
worshipers share prayers to keep those
on the front lines safe and their
families at home
supported chernihev was besieged for
weeks it looked bleak there was no power
no water or food
700 deaths here have been directly
linked to the war
and those are just the ones that show
obvious signs of trauma
yuri polk has worked for more than 20
years in forensics and has never
experienced anything like it
[Music]
most of my friends do not believe what
happened in our country and want to wake
up on 21st of february in peace they
have never seen such things even in
nightmares
the last of the invading russian forces
retreated in april but for survivors the
pain is still palpable
crystal comancing global news journey of
ukraine
farewell to the flower next canadians
pay their last respects to a hockey
legend
[Music]
his funeral happened in montreal but
hockey fans across the country and
around the world were paying their
respects today to a legend gila fleur
died last month and as dan spector
reports the people who gathered for his
funeral today remembered him for much
more than his talents on the ice
as the casket draped in a montreal
canadiens flag made its way toward mary
queen of the world cathedral hockey fans
across generations came to chant his
name
quebec bestowed the honor of a national
funeral upon gila fleur one of its
greatest hockey talents an artist on
skates an athlete with few peers the
flower died of lung cancer april 22nd he
was the centerpiece of the montreal
canadiens dynasty that won four straight
stanley cups in the mid-70s
not only did he play each game to its
fullest
he tried to live his life to the fullest
off the ice as well
the guest list a who's who of hockey
hall of famers for a moving ceremony
that sahab's legends like ivanko noie
and patrick
deliver eulogies lafleur remembered not
only for his on-eyes prowess but his
humility and generosity he's a superstar
but
very humble
very own bold superstar
i think as good of a hockey player
that he was you you knew
he was a better person that big grin
that greeted you every time you saw him
the archbishop of montreal presided over
an audience of tremendous influence
hockey leaders and elected officials
from every level of government paying
their respects
his contributions to
the world around him was
legendary and an inspiration to us all a
generation of fans looked up to the
demon blonde some braved long lines to
pay tribute as he lanes state at the
bell center sunday and monday hundreds
watched the service tuesday from outside
i'm sad but i'm happy to see a lot of
people paying tribute and respect
lafleur's longtime linemate hall of
famer steve schatt served as a
pallbearer i guess i got another
assist
you know we've been attached to the hip
for so many years the national funeral a
fitting honor even to his lifelong
rivals
it's pretty powerful stuff for
not only for hockey for fans for our
culture in canada as a kid he was my
idol but
as a player he paved the way
dan specter global news montreal
and that is global national for this
tuesday i'm donna friesen